let me introduce myself
i am raghavendran i am a research
consultant and mentor with pine biotech
and omix logics i am trained in
bioinformatics and i hold a
computational biology phd from max
planck institute so my research interest
in focus is on data science techniques
such as machine learning and deep
learning applied to integration of multi
or mixed data like genomics data like
transcriptomics data and like
epigenomics data etc so my role in find
biotech includes developing curricula
mentoring students in the research
fellowship program etc so for my
research projects i leveraged a lot of
publicly available data to infer very
relevant biological research questions
so please let me talk about one such
example in a very brief
couple of slides
where i developed machine learning
models to predict a tumor response for a
variety of treatment options
employing multi-omics integration of
transcriptomics data and genomics data
and copy number variation data so
i don't need to introduce you to the
adverse effects of cancer as we all know
cancer is the leading cause of deaths
worldwide so for such a dreadful disease
that we have known for a long time the
systematic cancer treatments have relied
on
using chemotherapeutic drugs that are
basically marginally more toxic to
cancer cells than
normal cells this is a huge problem
because on an average only 25 percentage
of the cancer patients respond
positively to cancer drugs but in
comparison about 80 percentage of the
patients respond positively to popular
painkillers that are available in the
market so one prominent solution to this
problem is to employ
something technically known as precision
oncological therapy where a treatment
strategy for cancers
designed by targeting molecular
characteristics of the patient's tumor
so hence the treatment is personalized
to the patients who are likely to
respond to specific cancer therapies
there is not sufficiently enough data
from cancer patients and not uniform
data from cancer patients to molecularly
characterize the tumors that we have
that we have underhand under multitude
of different treatment options that has
been currently studied in different
clinical trial levels so we have to
resort to a suitable model systems so
one of the suitable model systems is the
immunocompromised
mouse model which is also known as
patient-derived xenographs
this is done
by by transferring the tumor cells from
the cancer patients and before
transferring the tumor cells into the
mouse models
we subject those tumor cells to next
gene sequencing techniques and gather
information regarding genomic data
regarding transcriptomic data regarding
epigenomics data and regarding copy
number variation and other omics that
are currently under study so once these
tumor grafts or tumor cells are
translated or sorry transferred into
mouse models then
these mouse models can be subjected to
subjected to multiple treatment options
or administered several cancer drugs
that are currently under clinical trials
and study
to understand the effect of these drugs
and to understand the tumors response to
the respective drugs so this study
actually documents
the response of
tumor
breast cancer tumor and breast cancer
and colorectal cancer and other cancers
to multitude of treatment options
and have published this uh research and
this
and let the
data be
available publicly so this is done by
novartis and the
library and the data that they uh that
they that they have deposited and
uh um and is available freely is called
novartis patient direct xenographs
library or encyclopedia so this
encyclopedia or this this library has
both the molecular characterization data
of the tumor and treatment response that
are available along yeah that are
available in the big repositories so
this is a huge amount of data and so
much of data such a wealth of
information in the data generates a lot
of research questions and many many
research questions have explored this
data for specific purposes so my
interest was to use this data to design
and implement interpretable machine
learning models to predict tumor
response to different treatments so
in order to do this since we have
multiple biomarkers so since we have
multiple
omics data available so i had to employ
a multi-omics integration at a different
level so generally multi-omics
integration can be applied at
applied at different levels like as
early as possible or as late as possible
depending upon the complexity and
depending upon the
depending upon the
appropriate strategy that will help us
discover complementary information and
uh
maximize the information content
available in this multi-amix data so for
this particular data i had to include or
i had to integrate it at the late level
because of the
different distributions of the data
along the
multiple omics level
profiling so what did we find after uh
using this multi-year mixed data to
build the machine learning model so
before before the analysis i will just
try to tell the accuracy metrics that
are used to
validate the prediction accuracy of the
machine learning model that trains uh
trained with this multi-omics data and
tries to predict the tumor response
based on the separate test data that is
uh separately uh yeah um left over or
separated
so the the accuracy metrics is matthew's
correlation coefficient which goes from
minus one to plus one where the plus one
would this plus one would describe uh
uh
an absolutely uh perfect prediction
accuracy for the model and -1 would
describe a completely negative or
completely inaccurate prediction
accuracy of the model and anywhere
between zero is going to describe a
random prediction accuracy and
for the machine learning model that i
have developed developed so
traditionally for these questions or for
understanding the treatment responses
people have looked into the single gene
biomarkers that characterized as the
onset of cancer and they have tried to
find out whether these single gene
biomarkers can also be employed to
predict treatment response but we found
out this is not a very accurate model as
you can see from the graph when i use
the traditional single gene biomarkers
that characterizes this breast cancer
develop at a different
from different publication for these
different treatment options i see that
their prediction accuracies are not very
great but the moment that i include not
single gene biomarkers but information
from all of the genes genomic
information from all of the genes i see
that that prediction accuracy slowly
start to get better and i also see that
from the precision of the prediction
accuracy that is plotted for for all the
tumor for all the treatment options that
is given in this box plot so
the the availability of multi-omics
generally uh yeah requires uh as i
mentioned very complex integration of
this data to make sense so here
increasing the
increasing the information content by
including multiple omics data we can see
that
the
accuracy of the machine learning model
that trained from this data generally
increased towards or everything is going
towards
plus one
and and everything has a lot of very
good precision in terms of uh their
prediction um
spread so
this clearly tells us that there is a
lot of promise in using this multimix
data to predict the treatment response
using these mouse model systems one two
this also tells us by increasing the
information content one by including uh
one not a single gene instead of the
single gene markers by including
many more genomic information and many
more multi-omics information we can
increase the accuracy of the machine
learning model that predicts the tumor
response by learning from the
distribution of this machine learning
from this multi-mix data and
and three we can maybe probably extend
this analysis uh to a patient cohort or
patient information that we can
download from tcga repository just to
test uh just to investigate how a model
that is developed and that is trained
using multi-omics data that is generated
from mouse models can
or respond to
patient data from tcga repository so
what more could be done i mean
from these uh results we we obtained a
list of informative genes that are
currently being investigated for
identifying specific biomarker set of
genes that can define or that can that
can um
that can be inferred in a mechanistic
detail about the tumor response to
different treatment levels so
such i mean such
i mean these
research projects and these questions
can can be very i mean can be performed
by using publicly available data and by
using methodologies that are not
completely different from what you are
going to learn
throughout this program and throughout
the
process of uh
done throughout the
lessons that are covered in learnanomics
platform so we uh using the resources in
omixlogic platform will demonstrate you
how to perform such powerful impactful
research
and by using or by accessing uh publicly
available data so as you have been
briefed before
[Music]
the resources in this platform in the
omixlogic platform and in this program
in this genomic program is aimed at
introducing you to omix data and their
relevant analysis and this will
eventually help you
create or understand
or ask a highly impactful biological
research question that
you can start to explore on your own so
we will demonstrate you uh over the
course of this program how to perform
such high quality analysis on genomics
data we will also show you how example
projects that we have developed which
start from the first base of formulating
a hypothesis or exploring a data
designing appropriate analysis methods
and to perform complex analysis and in
the end interpret the results in the in
a
biologically meaningful way so as you
have always all been
briefed about the ngs
generate large volume of raw sequence
data so to analyze such a raw data many
different tools for genomic data
analysis are used and these include
yeah these include alignment of reads
and full sequences analysis of
relationships between these sequences
and their evolutionary divergence
measurements of the gene expression and
the relationships between
sequences and the relationships between
structures of protein that these gene
sequences encode to as well as
variations or variance in the gene
sequences and the sequences of the
genome that can be termed as somatic or
germline variants using multiple
different calling methods the talbot
bioinfo platform is an example of a big
data platform that can be
used or that can be leveraged to perform
all these analysis and many others used
in an intuitively user-friendly way so
when the analysis is performed using a
raw data which is usually stored in
fastq file format there are several
important steps to consider such as
pre-processing
mapping
variant calling annotation and
other associated steps also so for all
for all these steps and each and every
step we have at our hand a multitude of
algorithm that are available which does
basically a similar job but with a
slightly different uh
manner and slightly different protocol
so
in this program we will teach you or we
will let we will help you learn how to
use this pipeline and how to use
different algorithms that will suit the
data or that will suit the question that
we have currently in our hand so for
each task you can connect the analysis
jobs into pipeline and each one of these
analysis pipeline will
will include various inputs and will
have various outputs output
that uh yeah that you can download and
uh use it for downstream analysis
sometimes uh
when sometimes for the outputs it is
just sufficient to visualize the first q
alignment files to a reference geom
sequence to quickly get a sense of major
variance are too quickly get a sense of
how
our alignment
varies across the reference genome one
and what are the different mutant
variants that we can observe and that we
can find that are distributed along the
different genes and different parts of
the
genome so this is this is specifically
true or this is especially true when you
have a short sequence or when you have a
targeted regions that are sequenced and
these are very easy to explore but
however to explore a long whole genome
sequences and to visualize that and to
visually interpret that are extremely
difficult so a computational
interpretation and a computational
analysis is performed in addition to the
visualization that we can
that we can use where this computational
analysis
can call the
differences in the
first q read files to the reference zero
these are called variants and these
variants
are called from many reads and in the
case somatic in the case of somatic
mutations in cancer that might include
downstream annotation of found variance
based on the reference database so these
variants can include mutations at
different of different kind and for each
one of these kind you will have
explanation on how to interpret those
different mutations and variants
that are explained in the following uh
that are explained in the following
sessions in this program so
to visualize the
uh to visualize
the alignment of the first q files to
the reference genome we will use open
source applications and we will use
talbot bio info platform also to
visualize and to learn about uh their
mapping onto the different parts of the
genome so large peaks here i mean this
is the reference genome that is that is
in the gray area and where it has been
so far zoomed out that we cannot read
the
individual nucleotides as uh
as you have seen
that constitutes this genome and this
gray peaks large peaks indicate high
coverage in these areas and low shallow
peaks will indicate a low coverage or
low confidence in alignment as you can
see straight away from the gaps in the
reef that will not that did not cover
these areas and these
these vertical lines in purple or
pink lines will will tell you whether
what are the differences that we observe
at different points in the uh
in our sequence that are aligned to this
reference and in with respect to the
reference so such visual representation
and such visual analysis as i mentioned
might be sufficient for genomes of small
sequences
of
or of targeted sequence
experiments but when you are going to
perform such an analysis for
3.2 billion base pairs it is going to be
extremely exhausting that is going to be
very heavy in
for the computer to also uh work so
that's why
multiple downstream variant calling
methods and multiple downstream analysis
methods are employed to
analytically uh
quantify the variance
we we observe in our
mapped sequence with respect to the
reference sequence so a zoomed in
version of these variations or these
visualizations often include uh
visualizing visualizing in terms of
sequence alignment so these sequence
elements can refer to
excuse me two types of alignment the one
it can refer it can refer or it can be
aligned
to a reference or which is called a
mapping such as when you have a fast q
files as i have mentioned from a sample
and you wish to align each read to the
best position on the genome to find
whether these past q files or whether
the sequences in the read or the
multiple reads reveal a variation from
the
particular reference and in that case on
another case multiple sequence alignment
this is when you have multiple consensus
sequence that you would like to compare
with each other and to develop an
understanding of similarity among them
or between them so
this this both of these alignment can
also be performed in
in turbot bioinfo platform in many cases
the multiple sequence alignment can be
or is used to find structurally
important variation and it
such an alignment or such an analysis
can also be performed with amino acid
protein sequences that can be
that can be
obtained or that can be elucidated by
just simply translating the gene
sequences uh into their respective amino
acid
coding
sequences this is done by taking the
trinucleotide codons as elia has
mentioned and then translating them into
uh their respective amino acid sequences
so
the differences in both
the the genome level and specifically at
the amino acid level can often be
visualized and can often be identified
or
can also be visualized on the
three-dimensional structure of the
protein that is encoded by the gene and
the location of this mutation on the
protein structure and their effect on
the function of this protein structure
will enable us to make meaningful
interpretations of the variance we
identified as the result of genomic
analysis pipeline so in another way one
can use genomic analysis is by carrying
out
what what usually is called a
genome-wide association studies so to
carry out the grass or genomic
association study researchers use two
groups of participants people with
disease being studied and similar to
people without the disease
sometimes this can also include certain
variations of the disease or certain
conditions that are being studied to
identify
those genomic areas that are responsible
for this altered state or conditions so
researchers then obtain the dna from the
dna from each participants sequence
their whole genome and then
if certain genetic variations are found
to be significantly more frequent in
people with the disease compared to the
people without the disease as you can
find in some of these plots here
they can often be associated or they can
they are these variations are said to be
associated with the disease these
associated genetic variations can serve
as a powerful tool or powerful pointers
to the to those regions in human genome
where the the disease causing problem
might reside or they can be interpreted
as
as um
very relevant regions that are uh
associated with the disease this is uh
or the altered state that is under
currently understudied so the downstream
analysis of these found mutations
variations these snps and often
yeah these can be represented in or
presented
in a very different way depending upon
the purpose of analysis or depending
upon the purpose of the use case i mean
it can it can at its simplest form can
be represented as a table and at its uh
more graphical form it can be
represented as a lollipop plot and along
the gene sequence or it can be
visualized
on the three-dimensional structure of
the protein encoded by the gene of
interest ah and then it can also be
visualized as a uh yeah
yeah it can be visualized using multiple
different visual forms and can be
visualized
along the pathways to which multiple
genes that are associated with and how
these different mutations are these
different variations in these genes
attack there might affect the pathway
that involve these uh genes that are
currently under study so this
introductory course uh leads into
multiple courses and projects uh that
can serve as a springboard into the
world of bioinformatics for all of you
the curriculum for this introduction to
bioinformatics the curriculum for this
genomics course is carefully planned to
cover broad overview of different types
of methods to analyze the genomics data
and also to understand how this variety
of methods are used to answer very
relevant biological questions that are
found in research papers involving
genomic data and its interpretation so
to learn more about these analysis
methods and their applications in
various project examples you will often
be referred to associated lessons in the
genomics course series and also in other
courses in the learnomics logic platform
these lessons will include more expanded
overview of the key concepts principles
and examples of genomic data and
analysis
excuse me
these online courses cover or these
online course work on our
education portal will provide you with a
introductory materials that have been
used multiple times by thousands of
thousands and thousands of people from
all over the world and they have found
these perspectives very exciting and
each of these courses in the end also
contains quizzes and also contains
assignments that will help you or that
will allow you to see how much you have
learned from uh from this course or
throughout the uh throughout your
progress through these different courses
and different lessons so in addition to
these courses by seeing how experts
analyze their data and how these
impactful research
results are achieved
you can yeah you can start developing a
research question on your own to
identify appropriate type of data and
planning by and also to design your plan
analysis plan so for this purpose uh
we have in our platform have carefully
prepared some example projects that will
use all the skills and all the knowledge
that you have learned to infer highly
impactful biological relevance and to
answer high quality research questions
so these projects include a variety of
data a variety of analysis methods and
ask different questions that are related
to using genomics data and
and to
using multiple different align multiple
different analysis methods to infer high
quality biological interpretations so
these practical exercises and exposure
to data driven discovery using real
research data will encourage a critical
thinking uh for most of you and the
purpose of doing a practical assignment
on the purpose of going through
these projects that we have developed
and then
learning along with the projects that we
have developed
will
will help you
will help you gain a deep understanding
of these
multiple genomics
concepts and the
processing and the
analysis pipelines involved with it as
well as you can also showcase how
various methods of analysis are applied
in real world situation so in the end by
following through these example projects
and by also going over the course nine
which will help you in designing your
own research projects based on the theme
of genomics data or based on the theme
of based on the research area of
interest you can actually
perform or you can perform a project on
your own you can perform a research
project research you can answer research
question on your own and you can have
your own research experience that is
satisfying uh
for
for
satisfying for applying various skills
that you have learnt in this course so
far so that will
yeah that will conclude my uh
presentation i will take some questions
if you have any and if you have not i
can hand it over back to
malika